[Musique]
les uns ce thème le business pour moi
c'est résoudre les problèmes et
j'entends que ce monde se porte mieux et
qu'il soit durable financièrement et
écologiquement je fais partie d'un
groupe de jeunes gens qui veulent
s'attaquer aux problèmes de la société
et qui pour la première fois le fonds
via internet
j'ai la chance d'appartenir à ce groupe
enfants d'internet
docteur en philosophie matt flânerie se
définit comme un rêveur fainéants qui
veut changer le monde
il a mis en place un site de microcrédit
une passerelle entre ceux qui ont de
l'argent et ceux qui en ont besoin
lisez le box les utilisateurs viennent
sur notre site
ils y trouvent différentes personnes à
qui peuvent prêter de l'argent alors
suffit de quelques clics pour faire des
petits prés de 25 $ ils peuvent par
exemple décidé de financer un vendeur de
fruits en bolivie qui va est le premier
site où vous pouvez mettre un visage et
une histoire derrière chaque dollar
apparaît évident aujourd'hui et pourtant
ça n'existait pas avant qu il lancé en
l'idée séduit immédiatement qui va
reçoit des soutiens de poids
c'est l'ancien président américain bill
clinton qui en quelques phrases lors
d'une émission télé va faire décoller
laventure qui va avec le site de qui va
vous et moi nous pouvons découvrir un
ensemble de personnes à travers le monde
qui ont besoin d'argent
disons que vous choisissiez une
coopérative qui fabrique des pagnes au
rwanda en réunissant des ethnies qui
avant se faisait la guerre et qui
maintenant veulent vendre des paniers
ensemble et supposons qu'ils ont besoin
d'emprunter et 400 dollars et bien vous
pouvez leur prêter ses 400 dollars mais
vous pouvez aussi leur prêter 25 dollars
avec une vingtaine de personnes qui font
la même chose vous obtenez les 400
dollars qui vont toucher via un
intermédiaire local rwanda la
coopérative vous informe de ce qu'elle
fait de l'argent et vous rembourse
c'est formidable
gérant d'une start up de la silicon
valley c'est lors d'un voyage en afrique
que c'est fait le déclic pour matt ce
qui a fait que tout cela fonctionne
c'est que j'ai regardé la pauvreté sous
un autre angle
quand j'étais enfant je pensais à
l'afrique comme un lieu où n'y avait que
famines guerres et maladies la situation
en occident est très différente mais les
gens ont les mêmes préoccupations
je me suis retrouvé à parler business
les stratégies d'entreprise avec un
boucher ont bien deux chèvres tu dois
vendre et acheter afin de rentrer dans
ses frais et faire des profits comment
gères tu t'es marges
comment veux-tu te développer match
décide alors de quitter sa start up et
d'aider financièrement ces gens à se
développer mais il veut le faire de
manière responsable
pas question de faire des dons ou
d'apporter des solutions clés en main à
ces villageois ce qui leur faut ce sont
les moyens financiers de se développer
crainte ouest créée l'idée c'était de
mettre en place une sorte de mini bourse
virtuel au début notre concept c'était
de se dire ok elles ont besoin de 500 $
pour se développer
on va diviser cette somme on peut faire
et on va les mettre sur le site de kiva
que j'ai créées sans le moindre argent
aujourd'hui qui va c'est un prêt toutes
les dix secondes
500000 prêteurs répartis dans plus de 45
pays pour un volume de 75 millions de
dollars qui va ne perçoit aucun intérêt
sur les prêts quand vous faites un prêt
on vous demande juste de faire un don
pour aider qui va continuer son travail
ce don n'est pas obligatoire cependant
ce qui va et parfaitement rentable
[Musique]
pour informer les prêteurs sur la
manière dont l'argent est utilisé des
partenaires de qui va se rendre
régulièrement sur le terrain l'atelier
commence ici il a tout nettoyé et là il
fait sa publicité réparateur de vélos en
bulgarie angel à ses neuf ne parvient
pas à s'en sortir sans atelier ni
matériel il met son histoire en ligne
sur le site de kiva et l'argent arrive
aujourd'hui devant les caméras du site
de microcrédit pour informer ses
créanciers entre deux témoins et 4
coupes étaient alors angel cas tu as
acheté avec l'argent que tu as reçu
qu'as-tu fait de cet emprunt on a fait
plein de choses
pour commencer on a aménagé cette pièce
pour en faire un atelier de travail puis
on a acheté des outils des machines et
tout ce dont on avait besoin et angel a
pu ajouter une corde à son arc avec les
bénéfices engrangés il a investi dans un
chariot pour faire de la soudure
ambulante
voilà en quoi angel a été vraiment
novateur avec les bénéfices de son
affaire il a pu investir sur autre chose
qui va lui a juste permis de révéler son
potentiel
bref l'argent arrive
l'entrepreneur se développe qui va
informe les prêteurs puis l'argent est
remboursée et tout le monde est content
ça a tout l'air d'un conte de fées
et à dire vrai sens est quasiment 1
seul bémol l'agent ce local qui leur
apportent l'argent prend désintérêt pour
rentrer dans ses frais
mais qui va veiller au grain si une
agence de monde trop d'intérêts elle est
rayé de la liste finances et du
capitalisme pur et dur la pire
microfinance est opaque la prédatrice
elle joue sur l'ignorance des gens pour
les écraser avec des taux d'intérêts
faramineux de notre point de vue le
microfinancement réguler et bien
organisé est le système financier le
plus efficace pour redonner une place
aux gens qui sont les exclus du monde
et c'est justement vers ces exclus du
monde ceux vers lesquels les banques ne
vont jamais que qui va se tourner quand
j'étais petite fille ma maman faisait
déjà du savon avec la guerre tout a
disparu
j'ai voulu m'y remettre le savons a
toujours été dans les familles moossou
m'a ravi en sierra leone un pays dévasté
par douze ans de guerre civile
son père y aller c'est la vie sa maison
a été détruite à la fin de la guerre
aucun banquier n'a jamais voulu avancer
le moindre centime pour qu'elle puisse
refaire sa vie jusqu'au jour où elle
entend parler du site de microcrédit
habiter à la semaine pour donner la vie
mon premier emprunt fut 200 euros grâce
à cet argent j'ai pu acheter des
produits stockés de l'huile quand les
prix étaient bas ça m'a permis
d'accroître mes revenus tout au long de
l'année et d'acheter du nouveau matériel
sans cet argent je travaillerai dans une
ferme
j'aurais pas pu faire du savon mon rêve
aujourd'hui c'est d'aller vendre mais
savent en amérique
[Musique]
la dernière aventure pour qui va c'est
d'aider des gens pauvres dans les pays
riches
pour y parvenir il finance des auto
entrepreneurs qui peuvent démarrer une
aventure seul depuis chez eux
c'est le cas de tasses mine une des
premières à avoir bénéficié d'un prêt en
amérique vous pouvez retourner je vais
faire votre profil
j'ai demandé un emprunt de 6000 $ on m'a
dit qu'il y avait des gens à travers le
monde qui pourrait me financés pour
acheter des objectifs des filtres et
surtout un nouvel ordinateur qui me
permettrait de travailler mes photos
depuis tu as mines la photographe qui ne
parvenait pas à trouver du travail vit
de sa passion et l envie bien la
majorité des donneurs investi autour de
70 dollars
80% d'entre eux vivent en amérique
la majorité sont des femmes et la moitié
d'entre eux n'ont jamais entendu parler
d'eux microfinance avant de venir sur
notre site
on a créé une nouvelle communauté à
travers le monde
des prêteurs socialement responsable
[Musique]